we're not storing a key piece of data in
our weather table the location at which
the weather is going to occur this is
because we are going to use a separate
table for weather locations using a
separate table has several advantages in
addition to being more efficient because
we do not duplicate our location data
with each record it also allows us to
update information about our location
without having to update every weather
forecast record to implement this we're
going to create a relation between our
weather and location tables by adding a
column to the weather table that refers
to an ID in the location table this
column is created with the constraint
that identifies it as a foreign key
which is a unique ID from another table
what does this look like our list of
columns in the weather table has a
location ID which points to IDs in the
location table we can use this location
ID to perform an operation known as an
inner join inner joins combine the data
queried from two rows in different
tables into one row in the result when
we query the tables in this way we can
get any combination of columns from both
tables in this case we're getting the
location query from the location table
and the date description and min and Max
temperature from the weather table